Well, I like this first one a lot.
We can interpret an expression by walking its abstract syntax tree,
or its parse tree, recursively.
That's how we wrote eval-exp together.
To interpret the HTML we covered in class,
we need an environment.
Actually no, the environment didn't come up
until we got to JavaScript, which had variables.
The HTML we covered in class does not have variables.
So they don't change over time.
So I don't need an environment.
To interpret the JavaScript we covered in class, we need an environment.
Totally. JavaScript does have variables.
And since they can change value we are going to need to keep track of them.
Interpreting always produces a value or an error.
This was a trick, or at least it was very tricky.
When interpreting returns it either produces a value, like 5,
or an error, like type error--
you tried to add it into a string.
But interpreting does not always return.
It can loop forever.
If I write a program while true do x becomes x + 1,
that never returns with a value,
and it may never raise an error.
This is also known as The Halting Problem.